et pour en débattre à nous sommes avec
anne ahmad avocate spécialiste des
droits des étrangers et jean paul
gourévitch et les consultants
international sur l'afrique et les
migrations auteur du livre la tentation
et mouret le grand remplacement aux
éditions ovadia
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir sur arte france donc on
voit qu'au sortir de cette réunion à
calais il est question visiblement
d'améliorer la coopération conjointe
avec le royaume uni mais on comprend pas
bien puisque c'est est ce qu'on se
demande si c'est une décision finalement
unilatérale puisque les britanniques
étaient absents en raison de désaccords
avec paris la france a exclu londres et
pâle plaide en faveur d'une coopération
où est la cohérence
jean paul gourévitch
alors je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
cohérence possible je voudrais d'abord
dire que sid au delà des positions qu'on
peut avoir sur les migrations et sur
ceux qui en profitent et c'est d'abord
un drame humain bon et quelles que
soient
les opinions politiques là dessus moi
j'ai travaillé pendant 26 ans en afrique
il est probable que si j'étais dans
certains pays africains je ferais la
même chose que ces micro alors pourquoi
il n'y a pas de cohérence parce que
d'abord les anglais sont furieux du fait
que le nombre de migrants
traversant ce cimetière marin qui est
devenue la manche et la mer du nord ait
explosé on est passé en dix neuf ans en
2019 2800 en 2020 de 8000 cake et
aujourd'hui on est à trente et quelques
milles et on a beau dire que les
français sauvent un certain nombre de
gens sur ces trente et quelques mines y
en a quand même 23 24 mai ils sont
arrivés là bas donc ça encourage
effectivement les migrants à traverser
la manche et ça les anglais nous le
reproche parce que depuis les accords du
touquet la frontière est fixée en france
et non pas en angleterre en allemagne ce
qu'il fallait organiser cette réunion
sans le royaume uni est ce que sans
londres finalement c'est impossible
d'agir là sur la question urgente des
migrants à calais alors allez organiser
une réunion sans le royaume uni faut
rappeler que c'est une réunion comme l'a
dit c'est normal hein c'est une réunion
cros europe c'est à dire que on doit
discuter de cette question des
migrations et des migrants qui sont
malheureusement décédés dans cet endroit
uma mais on doit d'abord discuté en
famille si je peux me permettre cette
expression je vous rappellerai que
l'allemagne l'allemagne a demandé un
accord urgent entre londres et bruxelles
un nom revient évidemment hors urgente
relance de bruxelles puisque les deux
sens concerné c'est à dire l'europe est
concernée le royaume uni est concerné
mais on ne peut pas sans d'abord avoir
se dirait avis entre européens on en a
discuté avec lui d'abord trouver
solution européenne qui peut le royaume
uni ne fait partie de l'europe du bri
les choses ont changé il a effectivement
cet apport de tout mais il ya des
difficultés on ne peut plus mettre en
place notamment les accords de dublin et
les accords de chambéry pour les
réadmissions donc l'europe doit d'abord
trouver et en europe et
avec le royaume uni c'est pas une preuve
de lourdeur ça de la part de bruxelles
justement parce que cette question à des
de cette crise migratoire à akalé c'est
quand même une question urgente on a vu
ce qui ce drame qui s'est passé mercredi
dernier 27 morts au moins jean paul
gourévitch qu'on peut pas aller plus
vite quand même accélérer les choses on
sait qu'il n'ya pas de politique
migratoire européenne car ces migrants
ils sont pas arrivés par la france à
calais ils sont arrivés par un certain
nombre d'autres pays européens
et vous savez très bien qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas une convergence ni même une
cohérence entre les positions des
différents états de l'union européenne
donc ton sur ce point je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qu'il a edit tant qu'il
n'y a pas de politique migratoire
européenne
il est difficile de parler avec nos
interlocuteurs britanniques puis je ne
parle pas de la même boîte alors cet
accord que demande l'allemagne entre
londres et bruxelles sur quoi il doit
porter and had made
alors il faut savoir que il ya déjà un
accord et donc il existe cet accord est
relatif et surtout cet accord aux audi
est difficilement applicable
mon sens puisque la donne a changé
depuis le bris de vitre donc si il doit
avoir un accord aujourd'hui il faut
réfléchir sur les moyens qu'on peut
mettre en place pour satisfaire d'une
papa le royaume uni et en même temps
avoir un rôle du tir et de politiques
communes européennes contre
l'immigration alors l'europe aujourd'hui
on peut le comparer avec le rôle que
peut jouer la turquie concernant les
arrivées dont une grattoir sur le
territoire européen puisque aujourd'hui
la france est un point de passage pour
le royaume uni et le royaume uni
demandent à la france bon alors
effectivement avec l'accord de tous qui
est aussi un volet financier important
mais la france le royaume-uni souhaitons
toute la classe france sas le maximum
pour garder ou accepté d'ailleurs un
retour des migrants sur le territoire
français mais je ne vois pas pourquoi
continuerez effectivement à avoir cet
album là aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya eu
le break it qui vient faire évoluer le
droit et notamment convoi l'accord du du
bla et la corde chambéry donc le royaume
uni doit prendre tout simplement ses
responsabilités sur l'ex-site et
accepter l'évolution du droit sur ce
point un jean paul gourévitch là dessus
il faut comprendre pourquoi les migrants
veulent aller en grande bretagne et non
pas à sécher
d'abord parce que il parle anglais ou un
symptôme d'autre part complètes et de
votre part des migrants qui veulent
travailler et le
le royaume anglais
joe cole travail important et notamment
même si c'est tout à fait un peu
incompatible avec les normes européennes
de 6 et
de financement de ces travailleurs du
site et social
ils sont ils ont envie d'aller là bas
j'ai envie de travailler là bas et c'est
tout à fait différent de ceux qui
viennent en france car on ne vient pas
travailler il n'y a pas véritablement de
travail pour venir offrir tôt pour des
prestations médicales je chiale ou à
jouer à alan doss vous allez réagir à
cela mais c'était aussi une réunion pour
lutter contre la lah pour renforcer la
halle pour lutter que justement contre
les pacers à ce que ça aussi c'est le
coeur du problème
bien évidemment c'est aussi le coeur du
problème mais je souhaiterais d'avoir
revenir sur les migrants qui souhaitent
aller au royaume uni alors pourquoi il
souhaite alors aux emmy alors il est
vrai que maîtrisent l'anglais mais on a
pu voir à travers les histoires des 27
migrants qui sont malheureusement
décédées qui veulent aussi aller parfois
pour des raisons familiales donc il est
pauvre devenir avancé aujourd'hui que
ces migrants cette année au royaume uni
parce que en fait elle est rappelée
royaume uni alors qu'en france et a
bénéficié des nations bien évidemment
ces eaux et ce serait dire et manière
c'était pipé peut désigner et quoi
encore une fois dépenses qu'il est
question donc des peurs qui doit
travailler et forcément en relation qui
aurait signé d'ailleurs on entend ce
permanent il reproche au royaume uni de
ne pas donner d un format relativement
donc il faut une coopération pour lutter
contre les passeurs est il temps ou que
ans qui va au vol mais il s'est déjà en
place c'est-à-dire qu'il attache à
travail qu'il fait pour bien évidemment
essayer d'appeler les passeurs ya
énormément de personnes qui traversent
bien évidemment la manche mais il ya eu
pas mal de travail qui a pu être fait
bloquer le travail
alors parmi les annonces un avion de
frontex un kif qui va survoler la manche
à partir du 1er décembre jean paul
gourévitch l' agence européenne des
gardes frontières et des garde-côtes
dont les prérogatives sont jugées
mitigées voire inefficace pour contrôler
les frontières c'est une réponse
suffisante selon vous jean paul
gourévitch non c'est plutôt un gadget
même si le fait d'avoir un regard sur ce
qui se passe non seulement sur la manche
vous avez vu que l'avion de frontex va
surveiller aussi ce qui se passe au pays
bas ce qui se passe en belgique
donc c'est aussi une façon de contrôler
les moyens d'arriver à calais parce que
évidemment les passeurs sont beaucoup
plus organisés qu'il l'était autrefois
ce sont des véritables entreprises
artisanales peut-être pas complètement
industriel mais qui sont
maintenant efficace et dont d'ailleurs
l'efficacité est jugée positive par les
migrants il faut savoir aussi qu'il ya
un passage en grande-bretagne c'est
entre 3000 et 6000 euros donc c'est tout
bénéfice pour les pacers alors on ne on
lutte contre eux c'est tout à fait vrai
ce que dit ma collègue mais
les résultats de la lutte sont
extrêmement faibles d'autant plus si on
connaît très mal ce monde des passeurs
beaucoup de ces passeurs sont des mêmes
pays et parle la même langue parfois où
on la même religion que ceux qui vont
qui veulent faire passer donc il y à une
sorte de confiance voire de connivence
entre passeurs et migrants qui veulent
passer
l'avion de frontex penser que ce sera
suffisant pour éviter ce à nouveau 2
ce genre de drame que l'on a vu la
semaine passée
alors bien évidemment je ne pense pas
que cela puisse être suffisant mais
c'est déjà un pas dans la lutte en tout
cas contre contre les passeurs puisque
ça va être une surveillance de ce qu'on
entend tous quand même sérieux ans qui
sera quasi quasi permanente à partir du
1er décembre il faut se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi il n'y avait
pas de surveillance en tout cas on n'y
voyait rien avant le drame comme et je
pense effectivement que c'est une
volonté en tout cas qui est affichée de
vouloir surveiller de manière un petit
peu
quasi-systématique dorénavant cette
partie en tout cas de la manse pour et
éviter en tout cas montré au royaume uni
quand nous sommes en train de travailler
pour bloquer le passage des migrants à
chaque fois que l'on évoque justement
ces crises migratoires il ya une réponse
urgente humanitaire qu'il faut
évidemment fournira tout de suite une
réponse aussi structurelles mais pour
aller au delà justement est-ce que sur
le débat de fond j'ai l'impression qu'on
tourne en rond on s'attaque pas vraiment
au fond du problème à savoir comment
aider les pays d'où proviennent
justement ces flux migratoires à fixer
les populations sur leur sol jean paul
gourévitch et favoriser donc une
politique de coopération économique à
l'efficace
oui on a cru pendant très longtemps que
l'aide publique au développement allait
permettre notamment aux pays africains
de subvenir aux besoins de leurs
ressortissants on sait aujourd'hui que
les aides publiques au développement
même si elle est tout à fait utile pour
aider des pays à se développer n'est pas
du tout un frein aux désirs des
migrations jeu les montrer dans mes
ouvrages c'est au contraire une
encouragement aux désirs migratoires
donc le problème il est beaucoup plus
grave et ils durent depuis des dizaines
d'années et
il se pose de la façon suivante quand
les gens sont arrivés en europe ils vont
y rester qui reste en europe où qu'ils
aillent maintenant en
en bretagne puisqu'elle s'est retirée
l'union européenne la question c'est
beaucoup plus de faire en sorte qu' il
puisse y avoir des visas pour ceux qui
ont tout à fait vocation à s'implanter
en europe et des noms visa pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vocation à ce qu'ils ont
planté mais que ça parte à partir des
pays de départ ceci dit on sait très
bien qu'il n'ya pas d' immigration zéro
possible et que de toute façon ceux qui
sont décidés à partir chercheront tous
les moyens possibles pour le faire et
c'est bien attestée dans les témoignages
d'immigrants eux-mêmes qui dit j'ai
échoué j'ai joué mais je recommencerai
pour conclure justement sur cette
question concernant la politique de
coopération économique envers justement
ces pays dont proviennent ces flux
migratoires et aussi peut-être
peut-être sanctionner aussi peut-être
les pouvoirs autoritaires qui bafoue les
droits humains finalement et que
poussent les gens à quitter leur pays
d'origine
alors il faut savoir que les migrants
qui vont venir sur le territoire
européen n'ont pas tous la même histoire
alors effectivement et à ceux qui fuient
les guerres et à ceux qui souhaitent
venir rejoindre des membres de familles
qui sont déjà présents sur le territoire
européen ou sur le territoire anglais
puisque on voit qu'il y avait une
d'ailleurs des migrantes qui est décédé
qui voulaient besoins sont fiancés donc
ce ne sont pas toutes les mêmes
histoires et on ne vient pas uniquement
à des fins je dirais pour travailler
c'est aussi d'autres raisons alors la
question des visas alors c'est important
de montrer que il y à un durcissement
des visas dont il ya un durcissement du
royaume uni concernant la délivrance de
visas mais aussi un durcissement on
opère pour délivrer les visas donc les
personnes qui souhaitent venir sur le
territoire hors pair ou le territoire du
royaume uni vont tenter effectivement de
passer via des réseaux de passeurs ça
c'est une question qui est évidemment
interpelle sur pourquoi on arrive
aujourd'hui à avoir un tel flux
migratoires qui ne peut pas être
contrôlé est-ce que le fait de
sanctionner les pays dans vienne c'est
personne qui eux mêmes sont en train de
fuir leur pays pour des raisons
humanitaires pour des raisons de guerre
je suis pas certaine que ça puisse être
tout simplement bénéfique bien au
contraire ça va plus je dirais accentuer
une situation sur place de leur pays
d'origine qui va être beaucoup plus
compliqué et ces personnes vont essayer
comme l'a dit effectivement mon confrère
bon essayer coûte que coûte de traverser
en tout cas les mères pour tenter de
rejoindre le territoire européen pour
avoir une vie meilleure c'est à dire
quand on pose la question à ces migrants
de savoir pourquoi il tente en tout cas
ils risquent leur vie pour venir sur le
tour européen c'est tous pour avoir une
vie meilleure merci beaucoup à vous
annan mad avocate spécialiste des droits
des étrangers et jean paul gourévitch
consultant international sur l'afrique
et les migrations merci à vous